foreign
[Music]
what are you doing with my house what's
going on your father Jacob Holbrook when
was the last time you spoke to him when
I was 10 years old I'm confused
something with your parents died in a
car accident that's what I told you
Holbrook he's the marshkin guy that I
heard about on the radio he and another
prisoner escaped last night
Jacob Holbrook the so-called Marsh King
abducted Beth Erickson and helter for 12
years in the wilderness with the
daughter she gave birth to while in
captivity hope I'm not trespassing or
anything
[Applause]
I think he's coming for me
I wish he would have told me the truth
he gave me this after my first kill
these were the only tears my father ever
wanted to see you'll always be my little
Shadow now I realized a person I
believed in the most was really a
monster this means we're family
and means owned not family don't confuse
the two
[Music]
what's going on Elena feel like he's
has that been in your room the whole
time
you must always protect your family
[Music]
it's me
that's where we belong
I waited my whole life to see you again
I wasn't sure what I would feel when I
did
[Music]
I can still all be your family